it's nice to be outside let me set the
scene for our listeners we are out it's
a beautiful evening and we are outside
and we are at the Team Coco headquarters
here in the Larchmont area of Los
Angeles home base home base and there's
a wonderful porch and we're sitting out
in this porch there is not a cloud in
the sky it is a gorgeous teal blue
and uh everything is flowering because
we had a lot of rain this winter and
spring yeah and take it easy yes it was
great up until like yesterday okay can
you let me just set this I'm sorry okay
you're the worst
let's hear more about uh your very
descriptive patio that's covered
this is wonderful we're sitting outside
and we're sitting around a wonderful
fire the solo stove now listen the solo
stove
listen I'm not some shill but I have to
tell you this solo stove is incredible
beautiful design and we can sit out here
and it's a smokeless fire oh just wait
till episodes three and four we're gonna
be making actual Pizza in a Solo stove
Pizza Oven yeah wait they wait a minute
stop hold it talking are you saying yes
that they took the ingenious design of a
solo stove and then they somehow use
that brilliant technology to make an
incredible pizza oven that very thing
yeah okay but you're not a shill no not
at all
not at all but let me just say again
solo stove the one we're sitting by
right now even if it weren't also
capable of being a pizza oven is
incredible
um I've just never been happier sitting
here and I know sooner doesn't like it
but again the teal blue sky yes please
talk more the quiet the quiet song of
The Whipper will look the lone bird up
on that wire watching us oh look at that
bird or it's a drone that's a drone that
looks like a it's a you know what it is
a rival podcast
it's smartless it's those smartless guys
it's you know what it is that is and I
know that he's a tech guy but Jason
Bateman has created a drone and dressed
it they're so fearful of our podcast and
they basted it with feathers and they
sent it out and that's Bateman right now
you Jason Bateman yeah off
Bateman yeah we know what you're up to
right now he's watching it and well
here's he's doing two things right now
he's watching us through the Drone from
his uh luxurious home in the Hills uh
that I've never been invited to and he's
also watching uh his uh his appearance
in Teen Wolf at the same time he's
watching book two Teen Wolf too he's on
a split screen so uh here's to you I
salute I salute those guys I love those
guys yeah I don't know
um no of course not oh what do you mean
of course not I think
if they know me they think I'm cool
you're not in the club Sona there's a
celebrity Club yeah Sona yeah Matt Matt
and I are in Duck Club it's called it's
called the club we have a schwitz
Together Matt and I uh we go to Turkish
baths exactly
I'm okay not being in this club you're
totally fine with it now we hang out
with all the big celebs okay everyone
who's sort of like a c-lister on
Vanderpump Rules yeah we hang out with
and by big celebs we just we're talking
450 and over and wait oh like you know
all those really heavy people on vendor
pump rules
you start getting inappropriate after
one sip yeah I mean basically you just
had the equivalent of a cough drop I
know and you're going
nothing's happened I don't like that it
makes me feel like I fat shamed and you
know what I did pregame before this with
you oh please I had nothing okay all
right so you know I'm already feeling
just a little bit of nothing but then
you know we just feel fine I'll admit
that before this happened we walked down
the street and we went to a lovely Greek
restaurant because we had a lot of time
to kill we finished a podcast and then
we walked down the street there was a
lot of time to kill and someone said
let's invite Matt and I said I can't
hear you let's keep walking and weak
very nice outdoor uh Greek restaurant
here in the Larchmont area if someone
knew the name I'd shout it out but I
don't think anyone does this is called
Le petite Greek is it Le petite Greek
yeah yeah wonderful and you can sit
outside yeah maybe we had a glass of
wine maybe we had two I don't know yeah
the important thing is that I was
recognized oh Jesus
oh God yeah yeah no we had so many
people come up to me say I loved you in
that movie where you're the conductor
who's outed tar yeah
[Laughter]
at your comeuppance for
every month you change which kind of
strawberry blonde actress people mistake
you for because Tilda Swinton to Cynthia
Nixon to now I believe Cate Blanchett uh
it's also been Jane Lynch for a while
Jane Lynch right yeah yeah all those
women are angry with me
that's me exactly